I'm gonna work as a garbage man today
today we're going to be doing recycling
and Hollywood this is such a big car so
do you usually have to get up super
early you know some people start at a
more thirty it is early and it sounds
really bad but the earlier you get out
there the less traffic things not hard
to drive one of these things goes but
you get used to it very quickly this job
is dangerous
we are marked one of the top five
dangerous jobs in the u.s. if you're not
paying attention
something wrong could happen so how did
you get into that wanted a job with more
stability recovery service stops there's
always gonna be a job we'll stop right
here
okay three-point contact to get out
that's it
[Music]
there you go yeah just be careful before
you cross
yeah always look both ways all right
let's go doesn't seem like this is
really cool well it's not that full
right now but regardless of what's
inside we could either dump it so what
we do is that we latch on like this
and then this level will go forward now
pick up the garbage
and then we'll bring it back down and
then we unlatch it and all we do is just
pull back remember we always leave them
right where we found them you guys
wouldn't let me take out this garbage
right it's too dangerous
sue dangers is very heavy but like I say
if you were if this was your job Tyler
yes I would have to ask you to help me
this is men but regardless if it's a man
or a woman once we feel reassure this
they're gonna do the job and there's a
safest way we'll assign them the route
our next stop is right here stop - this
time we have a little challenge in front
of us we have an actual gate so you have
to remember and have all the little
clickers to go in the building
yes remotes whatever it takes remember I
connected yes oh it's the other way it's
a press deliver yet so move it to the
right to the right
[Music]
okay mixed up so what's the craziest
thing that you've seen sometimes you see
some weird stuff like animal remains
so PSA don't put animal remember in your
garbage or you recycle please this is
fun the next one trying to get faster at
this
all right hey it's part of the job don't
worry about you can bring it down all
right now give it back forward back 45
everything inside will play out yep
okay I'll get these two tiny pieces so
this is way less stops than you'd
normally do
oh wait less like a 150 less oh but you
have to look at it like one block there
might be five apartments and they go
really quickly last stop we hardly did
as many pickups as you usually do but
I'm wondering if we can just like take a
look at what's even in here the real so
I'm seeing a few things or actually a
lot of things in here at Thank You Rosa
there's a lot of things but that will be
all separated over there at the merc and
we'll separate from things that could be
recycled that can be recycled
only 9% of plastic actually it's
recycled route do you think it's worth
it picking up all of this it is you're
still gonna get the other part of that
you think you can recycle by picking the
garbage up I don't know up there if I
sorry the end of the day what we do is
that we connect our CG pumps into our
tanks there's just a feel up for the
next day PNG is one of the cleanest
natural gas that we can pump in our
vehicles it's cleaner emissions zero
emissions actually
[Music]